ashley tisdale suffered a major wardrobe
malfunction at the mothers day premiere
thursday on friday ET caught up with the
high school musical alum after her
embarrassing flip at the race to erase
ms gala Tisdale hilariously recalls for
Jeeps moment go through your mind when
you first saw the pictures really like
oh I literally saw the pictures on my
Twitter come on and I just started
hysterically laughing I was like of
course this would have happened to me
like of course but it's like one of
those things they just have to laugh at
it's like so ridiculous but it's like I
mean my stylist said do not wear those
they will CH be [ __ ] like you will see
them it was an option in the bag though
I was like oh it's an option maybe they
felt like I could know you got have a
sense of humor in this business you
really have to like that does not like
bother me at all Tisdale took to
Instagram with this hilarious reaction
after photog splashes caught a glimpse
of the actress going braless she
captioned the pic quote when you're
filling yourself but your gel pedals
want to steal the show hashtag dying
hashtag not my nipples hashtag free the
nipple cover the clip star stunned in a
modest long sleeve white beaded gown and
she has a new model for staying red
carpet-ready be comfortable and be very
comfortable to show off something that
you don't plan on doing but now I think
it just like be comfortable have fun you
know I kind of him someone who is um no
take things too seriously and I would
like to have fun